حسمت واجده لامر بكل وضوح وانهت مسارا
طويلا من التعاون العسكري مع باريس يعود
لبدايه ستينيات القرن الماضي خطوه ترى
فيها السلطات العسكريه استعاده لزمام
حربها على الجماعات المسلحه في الشمال
وتحقيقا لسيادتها الوطنيه وفي غمره ظروف
الاقتصاديه واجتماعيه صعبه يستقبل قطاع
عريض من البروتين هذا القرارات بارتياح
فرنسا شريك قديم وحاليا اذا لم تعد قادره
على تقديم اضافه للشعب ولا تقوم بالدور
المنوطي بها فلا اعتقد ان هناك مبرر لبقاء
قواتها على اراضينا قرار نهائي التعاون
العسكري مع باريس جاء بعد نحو اربعه شهور
من وصول النقيب ابراهيم الى سدته الحكم عن
طريق انقلاب العسكري
الفطره شهدت خلالها البلاد مظاهرات
متواتره طالبت باخراج القوه الفرنسيه
وبتعزيز التعاون العسكري مع روسيا ضمن
سيناريو يبدو استنساخا لما حدث في ماليه
قبل 20 خالد
نتحدث عن اكثر من 400 جندي فرنسي على
الاراضي البوركينابيه لكن السؤال هو
علاقته هذا الحضور او ما سيضيفه لمكافحه
الارهاب هناك اخطاء ارتكبتها السلطات
السابقه ربما لان بنود اتفاقيه التعاون
العسكري لم تكون واضحه وربما لا ترقى الى
انتظارات الشعب من هذه القوه
سعاحكم
بعدم تاثيره على الوضع الامني المتدهولي
في المنطقه منذ سنوات وكانت بوركينا فاسو
قد اطلقت حملات للتعبئه وتمويل جهود
مكافحه الارهاب ورغم تطوعي الاف الشباب في
صفوف قوات الدفاع وضل نشاط الجماعات
المسلحه المستمر في شرقي وشمال البلاد
والاخرى من ابرازها روسيا على توسيعه
علاقتها العسكريه والدبلوماسيه مع هذه
البلدان الجزيره